hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to until dawn now we've had
some revelations here and we've had some
weird shifts in storytelling over here
but there's something new over here Mike
faced a dilemma
why did Mike face a dilemma why is that
one in this one is this cuz who gives a
gun that's thematically about the gun
okay once bitten emily was bitten Mike
spared Emily probably for good reason
because it seems stupid of whatever you
hell you were doing over there actually
open the door saving Chris's life why
would she not have okay because if they
didn't have any romantic involvement
might have been left outside that would
have been a terrible turn of events we
don't have a lot more left until the end
of the game here which I'm guessing is
the result of a chaos exactly the title
of my memoir but anyway only a few men
have dared to hunt the Windigo I didn't
even flip can I flip thank you okay what
else we got very good I'll read this all
in a bit just I don't want to do
anything else
in case something going on boom okay
good okay the bite is harm oh the bite
is harmless
[Music]
wait see reassure why would you why
would you hide that you look really dark
the bites you it's not infectious it
doesn't do anything there you go
now we're not all crazy so she'll be
okay it says what fine fine Michael will
shot me as I shoot you and this [ __ ]
almost let him eat that
oh come on shall okay what the hell is
going for got in all the crises that
Emily's a giant mega [ __ ] although I
guess all things considered I don't know
it's don't forget to get the gun the gun
the gun the gun the gun the gun the gun
the gun the gun the gun the gun Oh
Joshua hello I don't know hours of your
choices people have died I know what are
you the YouTube comments
actively triggering events that lead to
someone's death or passively allowing a
tragedy to occur because couldn't lift a
goddamn finger to help someone else
remember last year no are you left your
poor sisters to die you did nothing to
help paralyzed by your own self-centered
fear while the wreath threat was closing
in no it's all about you Josh it's
always all about you
thanks buddy thanks friend
whoa okay that's gone terribly wrong
Oh baby baby can you feel how cold your
long illness hurt
it's yourself that you despise man
already admitted as much
let's see I didn't hurt anyone dad's on
Oh was like I didn't hurt anyone denials
didn't I didn't I but of course they
were your friends you misled them you
lied to them and you put them through a
night genuine her yeah fun so everyone's
definition of fun who's just a game just
yeah it was just a game I don't know if
any of my choices here matter because I
don't even remember saying and damn sing
thanks buddy how much will that be for
that therapy session oh my god guys look
we're skipping okay I want to reiterate
very closely I did not move my control
it was resting on the keyboard Mike he
was resting I was planted on the ground
there's no way that I moved it must have
been like it must have been like part of
the story at least that's the only thing
that I can consider because it only
makes sense that I mean only makes sense
in the cliched way that it doesn't make
sense that the navigator guide who
swoops in to tell important information
at the last moments of this monster
actually makes sense
lazy riding is dead killed died it by
the one enemy he's the only expert to
face and yet the only other person die
from it is Matt and that that I admit
was my own negligence but be honest
whatever I can't believe they forgot the
gun I know there's like in a panic tizzy
but god damn what the hell that's a
bunch of baloney I bet there's gonna be
some [ __ ] like butterfly angler told
Emily the information that she deserved
to know
and therefore everyone forgot the gun in
the big thing the slap fest what a bunch
of I'm gonna look if it's there I'm
gonna be really pissed
no one's been Ashley was faced with the
dilemma and told the truth
oh okay well I didn't find I guess
honesty is the best answer is opening
they were like but in truth telling
everyone forgot the gun only the most
important thing in this okay so I need
to be mindful because I saw a totem that
said that there was gonna be something
on the left side a credible threat all
right cool this is nice
glad I'm back here where's my doggie
buddy so was the mystery man the guy
that was smoking the guitars was either
now dead decapitated dude was he someone
else okay there wasn't anything behind
there I've already looped back there and
checked so over here I'm gonna find my
doggy buddy doggy doggy little Poochie
boo hey anybody boot Reno Poochie puss
yeah what are you seeing then I'm not
what are you looking at okay
oh is it Wolfie Wolfie who Jill Bobby so
why did he go holy [ __ ] I don't
understand anything
uh-huh
so was this or was this not the other
guy the guy who's now dead I don't know
what well I didn't even get his name I
don't think there was anything else in
there that I could get unless there was
and I'm a fool I've already picked up
the stogie so I already know about that
I don't need to look at this stogie
anymore because I've looked at it enough
okay so where did the wolves go I mean
what I got to do is I got to find
wherever the hell Josh's and why why is
Mike going off alone when even that the
guy told him that going off alone with
suicide and he's dead sieved you've
really gotta go
well then again he lived all that time
alone and was fine and then as soon as
he teamed up he died so maybe maybe
that's Mike's thinking here
still serpent's still stupid by by a
mile but I mean yeah at least he's using
something hey this looks red and
dangerous okay so what does that tell me
that just told me I was gonna be
ambushed I don't want to be ambushed
yeah I got it hmm yeah there was another
door back there that I want to check to
make sure it's not I just want to be
sure cuz I want to know where the
poochie's went where the hell would they
have gone cuz I'm willing to bet that
door over there was the proper way let
me see something here nothing over there
nothing over there nothing over anyway
how about right here this doors wide
locked actually yeah okay I just want to
be certain I just needed to be certain
because we can't leave the wolfy's
behind that would have been a horrible
fate I can't leave the poochie's me oh
that better be the sound of the
poochie's that I hear because they are
my friend now maybe I should have
grabbed a bone hmm wait wasn't that
totem just just out here way out here
wait hang on yeah that's exactly out
here that is impeccably right there yeah
I can't do it
wait I see the fence right there
something smells bad about this it's
literally it's right there it's this is
the place where this happened no no no
no that smells wrong that smells bad I
got a bad feeling about that I got a bad
feeling alright then
okay actually it looks like the
container that had the bones is now
collapsed upon that might be what he
said was like the whoa okay so this way
is blocked off this must have been where
oh well oh whoa what's this hello Hey
look at me look at me I found us he gray
with my perseverance I did it I did it I
got it whoa Hot Diggity Dog look at me
oh yeah okay torch first be a friar it's
four can a mob how about a shotgun in
some shells okay fine good enough for me
if I hadn't found this I would have been
um I could have walked out I knew it was
something I knew it had to be something
I knew there was some reason why that
was there yeah grab stuff every pocket
make sure you're a shotgun bomb walking
around I'm assuming you picked up the
game's logic of enough good shows you do
I want any more bullets yeah why would I
need more eco-terrorist here I got a
concern for everybody arrow and he's a
little bit of shotgun shells I'm not
gonna be greedy now ouch it feel Oh -
Chris okay now that I'm properly armed
they don't go out there without arms I'm
better now okay good that would have
been very very easy to overlook like
holy crap Mike would have been dead
instantaneously so good thing that
danger totem was right then and there I
really do wonder how many diverse way
there are to play this game like maybe
Matt would have gone with him if he was
still alive
and Mike wouldn't have had to gone alone
looks like he might encounter or
something out here any monsters aboot
hello
okay who is these people are these the
miners is that what I'm supposed to take
out of all this okay not that way wait
then which way am I supposed to go I
thought I was gonna be attacked
I was promised an earth-shattering
kaboom maybe I can shoot the lockout oh
I bet I wasn't being smart I bet I was
being exactly what the game wanted me to
be and I was supposed to get the gun to
be able to shoot up in the door over
here and then walk down the actual
bolted up corridor there fence up
corridor can I shoot you
right oh yeah wasting precious bull gets
Oh this'll be quiet
I think I'm deaf now it was already open
you didn't need to kick it oh well
whatever whatever it takes to be a
badass I don't even need to reload my oh
hey you Bobby you I yeah I knew this why
is this game think I forget everything
yeah I don't have a bone for you I may
have some spare fingers though I got
some fingers to spare yeah buddy
all right here's the plan I happen to
see a map of this place so we're not
flying blind
I didn't see a map it should be a way
through the psychiatric wing that'll
take us right outside the mine okay now
is there anything else here that I need
now that I got a friend who needs Matt
ah
Scoob and I gotta see this map he was
talking about because he was talking
about a map and I don't remember no Matt
being there that's a morbid clue all
right ooh wait I need to count how many
days
see tally of days I don't know
well a lot of days a lot of days okay so
you said something about there being a
map here oh and I wanted to read these
journals so I'm gonna take him in to see
this only a few men have dared to hunt
the Wendigo hi I'm the only man who's
ever kept them under control he these
words order shall be your death mine and
your death will not be the last the
Wendigo must be contained the Wendigo
grows out of cannibalism when a human's
desperate and craves food trapped on the
mound in this fierce winter storms when
he has eaten nothing for days the
Wendigos spirit will begin to possess
him even the strongest man as weak to it
he will kill without remorse often those
companions who have traveled with him
you'll eat the flesh raw from corpses
I've seen this happened many years ago a
craving for flesh that cannot be sated
the hours turn first and become milky
and white then the fangs become longer
like fangs the creature grows and the
skin is proved tossed across the bones
cool there was a tribe that lived in
these mountains the Cree their shamans
tell stories of a tall creature born in
ice the tribe respect to the mound and
all the animals which in here lived in
it the mountain became sacred to the
Cree every animal became sacred also the
Cree believed it was bad luck to harm an
animal in the mountain and would hunt
elsewhere whoa I done bad in 1893 the
miners arrived they found ten and later
traces of radium they mined deep into
the sacred mountain the crease say that
the mountain cried out and the Spirit
was released oh so was Jess is it just
actually dead because she killed the
bird I have no idea if that's how that
actually happened the one that goes eyes
Shane's they become both sharper and
more dim the Wendigo sees movements it
is a hunter like a hawk but it cannot
see stillness if you are to keep totally
still when the Windigo will not be able
to see you the skin and flesh of the
Windigo are hard like armor they seem to
feel no pain they cannot be cut or
stabbed bullets will not pierce their
skin though shotgun will keep them at
bay the ancient Greece shamans do this
you know back in the year one ten
thousand when they had them because the
wendigo is mutated from a human it knows
how to hunt us it can perfectly minute
it mimic its prey you must remain sharp
and disciplined I have killed six
Wendigos knives or bullets will not harm
them you
flamethrower it is the best weapon fire
envelops and burns away their skin and
makes him weak but try not to kill them
killing a Wendigo should be the last
resort death releases the Windigo spirit
into the air
I have contained them I use traps to
catch them and fire to drive them into
cages the traps were baited with human
limbs from those who had no further use
of them one by one I caught those who
had infested the mountain great alright
there may be defenses shamans Rodef
rituals I've found native artifacts on
the mountains and copied them totems
bunches of herbs and feathers I copied
they're designed I've tested them and on
the mountain they work they keep the one
to go at bay not entirely but enough but
inside buildings they do not work creel
engines say that the Wendigo grows from
the bite of another Wendigo but the bite
is harmless I have been bitten but I did
not change the only way is to eat the
flesh of another there's no other way
cool alrighty then now we know all that
good information thank you for a mr.
plot man
so this windigos particularly I swear I
did not move by it was literally like
okay like imagine this is keyboard it
was literally rested there I wasn't
touching it so it's a bunch of baloney
that it moved either was meant to be
that way
or it's a bunch of baloney I have a
funny feeling it was just meant to be
that way but you never know
good dokey boy calm down
maybe there's reason that he's not calm
maybe you need to be more aware of your
surroundings all right so is there
something over here
nope nothing at all move like you owe
fee no stuck on this side what do you
mean where did he go where did he go
where what are you gone where did he go
oh I see I didn't even see that
happening how would I have seen her with
my good hand
[Music]
awesome yay I can squeeze through there
I just need to lose a few more lemons I
know I have no use of them Oh No why was
I born so barrel-chested her oh that's
why I was born so bare-chested
why was that so important see that dude
that moves hey I guess I don't know what
any of that means
okay cool
glad everyone else forgot the gun by the
way I just remembered that they were all
stupid and I couldn't help him I can
only help so much there's inherent
stupidity late into this game well not
in the game it laid into the characters
in the game they're all inherently
stupid or else they'd be like from the
get-go stick together don't split up no
not even for sex
no not even for really hot sexy you
scream about before you do it at the top
of your lungs into the woods no no whoa
I'm super sad now
I'm glad the camera was staying on that
for like 10,000 hours thank you very
much huh oh my god who built like tanks
how crazy
[Music]
you know
oh wait well there was something ah
there we go let's now we're starving
freezing I will make you pay stop
testing us now yeah this this sanatorium
wasn't too friendly boy this this
mountain sure is cursed a lot is there
anything actually important to be known
from Locke huh yeah it's bad custom yeah
no joke why'd it have to happen where to
poochy we could have all been friends
wouldn't big happy family
maybe that wolf wait a minute
that wolf better be on my side I think
you're gonna move what was happening
there will be you don't hurry off wolfy
come back stay with me I'm the pack
leader or probably not maybe the totems
that I found are probably gonna be
useful soon I didn't see another toad
him on the ground so I possibly will be
getting one soon because I remember well
I guess you did just get a danger one no
coochie coochie where'd you go pootie
we were you ready to go poopy poopy
where'd you go where'd you go pootie
you better be okay you better be okay
over here right now run off again damn
it
spinning in friggin circles this look
like the area from the power drill mask
earth levels yeah be wing doctors off is
okay sounds relatively interesting
sure I'm calm I mean yeah I guess I'm
brave but this is just stupid why would
I go off on my own
let's make some noise it's noise baby
we're not okay there we go yeah rubadoux
Bujji
now that looks friendly
oh ah so the sanatorium was trying to
experiment with the wound a goes this is
gonna looper is it gonna be the same
thing he's probably gonna loop yeah cuz
that's how film reels work they loop
that's what they do okay so they were
experimenting with the wind dago's they
must have just fed him like a tiny itty
bitty little scrap of human flesh which
is not good and then what do you know
he's turned into a wound whoa oh whoa D
whoo I hope I'm going the right way
I mean by that I hope I mean I'm going
the right way for exploration because I
didn't I thought going to the B wing
would have been the obvious way Hey look
I can see something I found a secret
passageway oh hello my friend I don't
want to do this I I'd rather not but I'm
committed yeah no joke I don't know what
did I find a secret I hope oh don't mind
if I do you booby-trapped I only have so
many fingers left thanks buddy thanks
buddy
by the way you look handsome today oh
sorry old dude
to whom it may concern oh wait did you
stupid son of a sorry old dude okay they
are dying outside I hear them screaming
and crying this hell is my only legacy
God's punishment for my mistakes no
escaping my fate death awaits me now
Jefferson brewery near near Yonge okay
it's never on one of your fingers I need
the power of the wind to go to beat the
Windigo if you didn't know that's how it
works right okay so that was a secret
area so I didn't see a totem though so
uh
so that's interesting ooh was there
something over here I think I saw this
before it's getting harder and harder to
find these things yes please more
shotgun shells no oh boy information
almost this is good I guess like with
sanatorium medical examination alright
yep hello bro epidermal boobity boo
something-something will be whew
post-traumatic ketosis ooh that don't
look good
ectodermal dysplasia extreme nasal
septum deformation the scarring Aplysia
chronic ketosis yeah okay let's go with
those words he's turning into a monster
oh no we should do more we should make
more of him okay
still doesn't explain why that guy was
able to survive for so long on his own
but hey to each their own I suppose
alright I think that was everything that
I needed over there so with that being
said Boosh
I'm going to end this episode right here
thank you everybody so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done I might be getting close
to the end of this game thanks again
everyone and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]